well you know what man it's been a long
journey sure has buddy
we're we're about 200 episodes deep my
man thing is where we are you know now
that you mention it we are 200 and it
seems like just yesterday we were two
kids and Santa Monica and your basement
with with a zoom mic and I remember that
and hearts full of joy and we're just
trying to make each other laugh really
two guys is hanging out with a tank top
son young dumb full of [ __ ] remember like
it was yesterday it's it's crazy to look
back where we came from you know I
remember reaching down and Santa myself
brennon my dick always seems a little
bit hard sometimes you know what I mean
in other words I got all these hormones
pumping through my body and I don't know
what to do with all this energy and you
said Bry put it into the podcast I sure
did
something like grabbed a fistful of dick
yourself remember what I remember is it
was it went something like this you
approached and said hey man I'm not
doing well I don't know who to turn to
is there any way you could kind of take
me under your wing and show me the ropes
of entertainment I don't and I said sure
Brian I don't remember I'm sure it was
kind of it was kind of like a
make-a-wish thing I fell I remember you
coming to me and I was sitting there in
my expensive house surrounded by friends
I remember you were you were in the rain
you came in wet looking like a broken
bird yeah it's not in your nose and wow
yeah pants were stained I think you'd
peed yourself a little bit and you
walked in your knees were knocking your
hands were out and funny like you were
asking for something
remember you fell to your knees he said
I got nothing to offer but you're my
hero
oh wow and I want you to help me hey I
don't have much to offer but I'll punch
them in the face for you or you can use
my mouth as your own recreation center I
didn't know what that meant and I don't
remember like that right see oh you know
it's coming back to me now that you
mention it yeah I remember I was at a
restaurant with man I got a great group
of friends yeah and I remember sitting
around I went to the bathroom and you
kind of barged in on me hmm he went hey
man I know you don't know me but I've
made a lot of mistakes in my life yeah
is there any way you you'd have the
heart to do a podcast with me and I
don't know man maybe do everything for
me and I thought to myself I remember
god damn I mean can we play that track
back I remember thinking to myself
goddamn look at this 47 year old just
just broke he's broken I remember you
said and I remember thinking to myself
with my help he might be alright and
then you got on your knees I went what
are you doing you went it's just a
special day it's too
he's running a repeating cafe ma copy I
wanna read a lot over here what do you
got eV all right I'm fine are there any
fights this weekend there or not
okay did you I watched Bellator late
last night about mid tide midnight I
watch it recorded him Bobby Lashley yeah
Jack Jack other than that
whenever Kendall Grove WASC and Shamu
link oh the dude look great I hope they
give him like he's asking like dude let
me step up in competition cuz he's five
known Bellator and he's like let me
fight somebody I think it's time he
looks good too though man what's this
first one we got Shane Carwin a treat
tweeted a photo of a rising Fight Club
and said that he is accepted a fight
with fate or Emelianenko the only person
who has not signed it obviously fate oh
so it's not official that's abut this is
an offer on the table yeah I'll tell you
what I don't know why else you would
sign with Rison unless they offered you
a for-sure deal with fade or other than
that who the [ __ ] is she in the fight um
you know I love Shane like a brother I
don't think it's the best business move
you know I know his manager has a lot to
do with this but if he gets phaidor then
this this move paid off I don't know the
ins and outs of the contract I don't how
much he's getting paid so I can't
comment on that but why you wouldn't
sign with Bellator and the stuff they're
doing is crazy
to me as much as the you know the media
and stuff like that if you think guys go
away when they start a belt or sign with
Rison unless you fight with phaidor yeah
there's nothing for me
oh we don't know hopefully I would
assume what other heavy was that would
that'd be though with then one well
maybe we don't know that that's why if I
could comment way more if I knew the ins
and outs of the contract is can he fight
phaidor cuz remember
phaidor and Bellator kind of cool they
were gonna do like cross promotion stuff
like that so maybe by sign with them you
can jump back to Bellator something like
that that would be the move can you
fight fade or they can come to Bellator
something like that but don't says let's
say alright let's say knocks out Fedor
then what do we do next well what they
have going on and rising right now is
they have they have the open weight
tournament that they're setting up right
now in Vanderley Silva's Rd and Cro Cop
is already in if Carwin and phaidor get
added to that open weight tournament
that's maybe that's like that's one of
the opening rounds bouts
that's [ __ ] bad-ass again but hey so
hold on Cro Cop and Wanderley would have
to fight Carwin and open wait they could
I mean yeah it's open weight tournament
price yeah bless them enjoy that bond
early to small he's so fun to watch
John Jones's attorney says that asada
has independently confirmed that the
product that Jones used was contaminated
which with the banned substance that he
tastes tested positive for ahead of UFC
200 I like people that go no bro you're
still responsible for what you put in
your body regardless nah [ __ ] sometimes
we take protein powders something like
that or John had a sponsor we thought it
was good to go because they're big come
and they work with them and he's passed
us before they're all something there's
some shady supplements in there this
well I mean I guess this is all from
Jones's attorney this isn't from USADA
so taking Jones's attorney's word here
he said quote we've been able to
establish the source of the prohibited
substance it came from a product that
John took that was not labeled with
either of these substances we had it
tested the product was contaminated with
both of them I know who sada also
independently had the product tested
their testing confirms what we found so
he should be we go his hearing is
scheduled for October 31st
to be I don't know but I'm just saying
that what this is saying is that there
was a product John took that had
substances that were banned in it
however we don't know if that also
precludes then that he definitely so in
other words that's what they found they
found the substance the banned substance
in his system and they and they yeah and
they tested the products that Jones was
taking they found that the products he
was taking were not labeled with this
banned substance there is no indication
that it had the banned substance in that
yet they were able to confirm that that
product did in fact have those banned
subs so he under he did completely
unknowingly take ingest these stuff so
his his arbitration hearing is on
October 31st looking at a maximum
one-year suspension or could just be let
off with a warning
war this is what he's me fight my early
action back in yeah that's so stupid
yeah let's get this back Brian I do you
do on the pike I think so you touched
and pious when you went for that crest
commercial ad that might be the hardest
I've ever loved I made you laugh harder
you know it it's kind of we get this
question that our two hundred happens
now I think my I think maybe the hardest
I ever laughed was the French robot
story yeah I don't know why something
about that just [ __ ] killed me and
you and you and your college roommates
dressed up as big babies and diapers so
it's a visual story that is I just kill
me and any time Sasa's on here like
oh my college roommate punch yourself in
the face
they've been some funny ones uh you know
well that was on Rogaine here the time
Callie got molested you know the stories
just came to me and I was like we were
like a hundred so it's deep I like you
no no no all I know is that when I got
when Brennan and I both got an email
that said Chael Sonnen is in town do you
guys want him on the podcast we both
responded with capital letter y e s I
said you bet your sweet ass and enlarge
exclamation points hell yeah I want you
on the show what if you know what Chael
Sonnen I'm sure you're probably not an
American now I leave my country now last
time you were here we talked a little
about fighting and I was like hey man do
you think in a fighting
I don't think so Brandon I really I
don't I mean I would like to but I don't
think so and then two weeks later jail
sign no hold on though to be fair he
also said I've never I have not yet
given up on the idea that I'm not gonna
fight again I wanted to want to fight
you know I wanted to want to do it but
it's a process you know going out
walking in the arena and doing all that
stuff that that's the fun part but man
the training is tough it really is it
it's tougher and tougher it gets tougher
and tougher in Europe every morning and
Oregon it's raining you're out in the
rain and you're running I mean it's just
a process it is what it is but I think
that is part of it works like man I want
to want to do this but it's it's a
process so what made you want to do it
because obviously the reason why trainer
trainings tough is because you're older
right because when you're young you know
I'm sure you could train all day and
night
then the older you get the training it
gets a little tougher you need more rest
days yeah well there's that with the age
but I was also in the testosterone era
and and the one thing about testosterone
is it is a a recovery medication so you
can get through those workouts or go to
bed where you can barely move wake up
the next day and just feel great again
so when that all went away
I mean that mattered you know that that
affects it I can't do now what I used to
do but largely it's just because of
recovery and in any ten-minute period I
can go hard or 50 or whatever it is but
I can't go do two hours with the college
kids and stuff like it which is what
testosterone helps you do which is what
testosterone lets you do yeah I mean I
could go do a two-hour college work out
but I couldn't show up the next day it
through every single day day in and day
out it's got to change a little bit I
hear guys talk like that and you know I
big one was I don't train harder I train
smarter but that is a precursor to I'm
going to lose every guy that I've seen
say that that's training smarter instead
of harder man the guy that trains harder
wins it happens almost every single time
and I did not want to fall into that
trap but the reality was you know with
how the testosterone or with the age to
your point um it gets a little bit less
and that's a tough battle
have you ever drawn somebody where you
went [ __ ] oh yeah I got ahead of John
Jones fight and you know I was prepared
for that fine girl okay I'm gonna do the
best night but did you did you know
logical person I'm going man this is a
tall I just got cleaned up before I had
to fight John Jones it wasn't like I
forgot that that had just happened right
so I'm putting on you know my public
persona and I'm trying not only trying
to convince me I'm trying to convince
myself and I thought I had a way to go I
mean I trained really hard for it I was
doing good in the gym that's just a
different animal right it's a different
answer let me ask you that you do not
call out a smaller guy it is a cowardly
thing in the world of jiu-jitsu a black
belt does not go after a purple now it
could be the other way around the purple
come after but you just can't do that
okay Rory's a stud and can defend
himself so I think that there's a little
bit of grace there special case yeah but
it was a situation where I I read that
about Rory I knew that he had signed I
want man that division is still forming
I know what he's gonna do and then he
even said I'll move up and wait I'll do
these different well yeah I know I'm
breaking a rule here but I think it
might work for all parties yeah Andrew
Roy's also you keep down that size B but
he's one of the most skilled guys in a
world and he trains the bigger train
partners the fight would make sense I
don't like your Ferrari right now if I
once got Coke I don't do it right what
about those rolling leg locks that he
was going for in the Steven Tong and
almost had him yeah I thought he was
gonna get Stephen Thompson on one of
those yeah you don't know what Rory's
gonna do Roy's crazy so what with Tito
that does this fight
site you know because we all train
together I think it was you me and Tito
a train were you there when Tito's no I
wasn't there I miss him I thought he was
gonna be there and essentially it just
comes from jealousy I had Tito and I
were the same weight class in the same
conference in college so is so we met up
inside each other he left college and
six months later was the UFC champion I
wanted to go down that route I wanted to
be an ultimate fighter and I would sit
back and watched Tito on TV and it was
at a jealous did you wrestle not did you
guys go against him in college but you
guys we had one match how'd that go uh I
beat him it had it was his beat him
pretty bad and it was his birthday I
caught him right off the I throw my head
Norman pinned him and 40s on his
birthday on his birth damn Joe come on I
don't say that to put myself I will
admit that I caught him but yes it
finished in a pin and I've never brought
it up I've never told anyone we've got a
video of it I've never put into a video
yeah he put it out and so I thought okay
well this is fair game I never want to
use that against him however he did get
his shot and I remember one of the
biggest struggles I had won to get in
this business was just getting the shot
I'd be sitting on my couch I was in the
practice room with world champ we had
Randy Couture and Dan Henderson and Matt
Lindland Evan Tanner I knew where I
stood in the world oh all right first
current event we got today we will go
with holic gracie metamours founder
holly gracie
signing to fight with Bellator he's your
coworker yeah man I found I found that
signing interesting what I didn't know
Halleck didn't MMA and I he's got a
background I want to say he's even three
you know but I didn't know he was
actively doing MMA I know he's got a
grappling strong background he grappled
in his own show he was beat by Gary
TuneIn it surprised me because I didn't
know he was interested in doing it yeah
it it can't be a good move you know he's
he's in a little bit of debt debt with
metamoris and he's doing all he can to
kind of get cash I think and this is the
next play originally metamoris in him
competing as Gary tonin was to you know
get money because he stopped paying the
competitors so that was the only way he
could make that happen so I think this
kind of a
cash and grab situation sure I don't see
it being a long investment you know he
has the Gracie name I think that's what
Bellator is going after he doesn't you
know he's not a fighter
he fought years ago you know when it was
back you know black and white basically
and Jason fought since 2010 and he
fought Sakuraba
yes and so how do you do against
Sakuraba he beat him last twenty fighter
lifetimes so I don't like it when ya
still good win no matter who it is so I
think I think it's just you know it's
for cash into trying to settle this
metamoris debt and you know people that
he owes money to but that is the wrong
reason to get into that cage man it just
is and then the big thing for me is you
know you know things are bad when your
two brothers Henner in here on send out
a mass email to their context one we
don't associate with anymore don't do
any business now Gracie she's burned
every Bridge he's using our name we've
we've worked way too hard for this
please don't do business with him we
we're like I say a while ago I mean like
eight hours go right you didn't hear
about that did not hear ya they came out
they sent out an email they even went
public with it and and they were it
really wasn't a scorned email as much as
matter of fact let's be a private email
yeah he had done some bad business and
we just we don't want to be associated
with it we do good but I mean it was
real matter-of-fact and you could tell
it was hard for them on their own
brother I mean I would have to think it
makes Thanksgiving a little bit awkward
but at some point they just kind of went
look with it just so everybody knows
just so we're clear on this those aren't
our promises those were his yeah and so
you know Henner is one of the best
businessmen that I know it just happens
to be one of the best jiu-jitsu
practitioners on planet earth too and
they've built this business especially
the Gracie University online and you
know they're there Academy and Torrance
is enormous and they're known for the
reputation then you have how it come in
the situation with metamours where they
kind of spawn for a little bit but once
you stop paying guys start doing shady
deals and there's some credit card fraud
and then you're not paying the the
competitors then it's just a bad name
munchies yet sure and then this is where
I
he just needs he just needs to drop the
ego and just needs help because
someone's like a man you're just taking
these fights to pay debt and stuff like
that and with metamoris you just need to
stop you know you're not doing just to a
service and he responded back and
definitely shouldn't be on social
meeting goes metamoris isn't around to
pay anyone's debts
it's to put on the best use to
competition in the world that's it and
the guys like yeah but you're promising
these guys money you're not paying them
that's a huge issue he's like that's not
we're in this business for yeah well hey
man I mean we're both two guys that
competed metamour it's right yeah yeah
if you give your word you got you got a
pay and I thought that was his mistake
I'm an intent guy more than what
actually happens I don't think he
intended to screw anybody I thought he
was gonna do better I think he thought
he was gonna do better business and he
did at the end of the day he came up
short a community came up short yeah and
that would have been the great time to
just come clean and go this was a
business move it did not work I am now
bankrupt thank you all instead he tried
to move on and just hustle the next
group of guys and that's that's where it
became really tough that's a lack of
experience fact what you're saying the
cover-ups worse than crime cover-up
sports in the crime if you would have
just come cleaning on guys' fell on our
face I'm out everything and by the way
I'm not paying any of my bills I just
want you to hear it from me it all would
have been forgiven I agree yeah and Baba
looey even came out said that babalu
comes out and goes how much it's a guy
used to pay to do jujitsu
I would pay to enter tournament I have
no pro I'll do jujitsu for free but the
problem is you said you'd pay me so now
you have to pay me or your dirt bagging
but and that's babalu is that's a very
fair point it's hard to argue around and
yeah that was hallux that was hallux pro
i did business with him
I would go back I had a great time at
metamoris I had a great time watching
you inside work I remember yell I was
the only one cheering for you in the
whole building
yeah you were I was sitting the front
yeah but I loved it I loved your style
and your strategy I was even saying hey
if you guys don't like what he's doing
change the rules but he's following the
rules right now and he came up with a
strategy and that's what's got you all
upset
Brendon showed up with a strategy I
would do business with Alec again but I
understand why other people want it yeah
how long has it been since Brian has
someone to suck as I have a hard-on
but he has it at least hasn't said
anything what do you got here right what
we got here is Michael Bisping saying he
verbally agreed to fight GSP at UFC 206
he was actually offered the contract
this isn't just like a verbal kind of
deal he was offered a contract
Bisping furbling greeter didn't sign it
but yeah he verbally agreed to it and
GSP is not down for it from what I hear
he was offered quite a hefty sum hold on
so GSP was offered a hefty sum yes to
fight Bisbing okay him and Dana couldn't
come to terms just be already sent a
video out earlier like a message to
Bisbing say okay me and Dana couldn't
come to terms couldn't come to the terms
we wanted so it's not gonna happen and
what you're taking on because I saw
Bisbing to it out come on be the be a
hero in your hometown we all want at
your money but just take the fight
that's my problem with the sport that's
how that's how things will never change
cuz you got a guy in GSB who let's be
honest doesn't mean more Fame probably
goes down as the greatest fighter in the
planet right now doesn't need money
doesn't need Fame he's like nah man you
pay me for a while I'm worth I had Under
Armour pay me this much money you owe me
wear this [ __ ] Reebok now fight for
that I'm not gonna do that
you want me to honor my old contract
when I sign that contract there was no
Reebok deal with the we didn't have all
this stuff going on so you're talking a
different time and then you got guys
like bismi I love bhisma it you just
take the fight what everyone wants more
money it's like that's the issue man
nothing's ever gonna change if GSB signs
that fight yeah so if I can back up just
for the listeners because there's a lot
relevant what you said Jesus peas last
fight was 15 minutes after my last fight
so I know the time for him I was co-main
event I passed him in the hallway after
getting beat up by Rashad and he was
walking out to defense so we're the same
timeframe the relevance there that was
in November of 2013 in early 2014 is
when Reebok stepped in now this is where
it gets interesting I hope I say this
one I don't lose you guys he had a
contract with the UFC when the Reebok
thing came in there is an addendum that
has to be signed
if you amend a contract it's essentially
a new contract so George has to come
back in and go no you must honor my
contract you have X amount of
days to give me a fight or you have to
pay me anyway ufc's going happy to do it
love to have you fight and need this
addendum sign because we've got a new
deal with Reebok and we'll go ahead and
put you in there and George from a legal
perspective has legs to this argument to
go no I have a contract and I expect it
to be honored so the UFC then gets to
come out and go we'll wait you came out
you verbally froze your contract with
this quasi retirement so we're gonna go
to court to figure out are we actually
at our deadline where we owe you a
contest or did you freeze that and we've
still got some more time and you're not
a free agent so there's actually an
illegal argument that can only be
decided before a judge which favors the
UFC because he froze he froze his
contract when he retired or at least
they can make a claim to that and if you
make a claim to that the only person
that can decide it isn't lawyer is judge
it's a judge so now you have to get in
front of the judge that could take ten
months that could take a year the UFC
could move there's gamesmanship that
could happen there which would would
side with George to go out and fight now
what I personally believe and I got
suckered into this because I'm at George
mark but I personally believe he has no
intention to find took me a long time to
get to this I finally rose he doesn't
plan to fight he's trying to keep his
name out there he's succeeding he's on
shows like this he's everybody's talking
about him and this is how he keeps those
sponsorship dollars coming in that's
what I believe is trying to happen
because they tried to put him with Conor
they've offered to put him with Tyra and
they offer to put him in there with
Lawler they're now offering to put him
in there with Bisping and he's not doing
yeah but it but we don't know the
financials sure okay I love the fight
listen Conor McGregor comes out he
brings an absolute storm and what
happens is most guys aren't left Stan
and when that hurricane runs through
nobody's running over Eddie Alvarez it
has never happened it isn't gonna happen
you can beat Eddie what you're gonna
need some time and probably the judges
and maybe things don't go that way
nobody is running over Eddie Alvarez and
if Connor comes out and tries to do it
and I think he needs to try to do it
he's a front-runner much like Vitor and
then just hope nobody's left standing I
just don't think he's got the endurance
and Eddie Alvarez is the real deal no
two ways about he's a world champion but
so is Conor I just don't at 55 I talk
about this all the time I just don't see
and I'm the biggest Conor you know fan
boy in the world at 55 I just don't see
matching up well
those top five it's not a fun career for
him at 55 it's never happened before and
you know so many fighters he'll come out
and said you were a guy wins two belts
simultaneously in the UFC I want to say
this and I'm switching gears just a tiny
bit but I'm frustrated I'm frustrated
the stupidity of fighters and I just
can't take it anymore
fighters are weighing in saying you need
to strip Conor McGregor now guys are
coming out from other divisions that
have no standing in the matter ate an
85-pound just came out said you need a
strip Conor McGregor and said guys do I
really need to explain this to you part
of the storyline of this is that history
has a chance to be made that Conor
McGregor has the ability to capture two
titles simultaneously to use Trump's
point from a marketing angle if you're
the UFC why would you possibly through
the power of the pin do away with one of
the greatest story lines that you have
leading into this contest why can you
guys not understand if you're Dana White
and you come out and you reveal that to
everybody it loses its allure it's like
guys connect the dots here let him have
his moment let him hold the two belts up
let that picture go out there forever
should he be able to do it and let us
have the headlines there is a
trickle-down effect in MMA I'm over in
Bellator we will feel a trickle-down
effect from from the Madison Square
Garden card they wouldn't gut you we'll
be in New York before you know World
Series is going to New York there's a
trickle-down effect go ahead and support
your racehorse while he's running but
that racehorse with that racehorse who's
you know if he is holding both belts
simultaneously besides Connor who else
would they get behind name a big draw go
it's tough right now give me one though
chill yeah I gotta go with Ronda and
she's not even fighting and then you
know you see what she's been going
through how many does she have left sure
yeah no absolutely so you got call me a
poster boy you know yeah
and Rhonda's big I don't mean this
negative all Ronda is not as big as they
say she is Rhonda has never done the
gates or the pay-per-view sales that
Connor does and they continue to say
she's the biggest draw in the Indiana
does yes he does and I have never very
on that I have a theory if you really
want to get into it
so Dana goes she's the biggest fighter
we've ever had then you see blah blah
blah I saw it that's not true number
wise it's not true you can say oh well
jobs
I know let's just look at the numbers
Connors the biggest fighter you've ever
had Brock Lesnar was huge Chael Sonnen
was huge Rhonda's not huge in that
respect I I would assume you know Dana's
human so he's gonna be biased Rhonda and
Dana shared the same agent at WME okay
so there's gonna be some biased
favoritism when he says yeah I just
never understood and maybe that maybe it
comes in as simply as that look there's
some backstory and some politics there
and she's a huge star I'm not
questioning Rhonda at all
but she is not look she's always been
second to Connor since he's been on his
run she never touched Lesnar nobody did
that was an anomaly George st. Pierre
did it's great numbers I've always just
been a little bit confused why are they
saying that because a lot of this is
verifiable we can verify I'd be her sex
this woman superstar infighting we can
look around the building and see what's
sold out here or not I was there when
she fought Sara McMann and you know
there were 7500 just the reality is what
was sold there's there's clicks online
and in certain things and she does
really good business you know how market
is in social media for you to say it
enough times it becomes true it becomes
free-associate dana says it yeah because
gold he's always pushed I'm like that's
not true and then when he goes she's the
best female fighter in the planet I also
have an issue that cuz I I've seen
cyborg fight and I see right now I'm
like there's not a female on this planet
right now who can beat that one that's
ever been born yeah and I was late to
the cyborg party and I'm too I don't
want this to sound anti I just never
understood yeah I was raising late to
the site I hated all that girl for years
then when she came to the UFC I'm like
well she passed the drug testing and she
is stalking these girls just I mean it's
like holy balls I don't know and I'm I'm
tirana I mean yeah we on on Team Ronda I
don't see anyone competing with side
work yeah this is my then this is my
issue with it if Dana's gonna say you'll
run is the best ever
blah blah blah this this and this and
you have this girl cyborg who is working
her ass off me god you want to have
someone who earned their keep in the UFC
and she starts on these girls and
there's just no marking behind that girl